RACHEL O'MEARA: Thanks for
coming today to our talk
at Google.
I'm Rachel O'Meara,
and I'm based
in San Francisco at Google.
I'm really excited today to
bring in Karen Henson Jones.
Karen is here to talk today
about her spiritual experience
and journey with a
near-death experience.
And I'm really interested
to hear some of the things
that she's going to
share with us today.
She has a lot of, in her
book, "Heart of Miracles,"
data and scientific
evidence that she provides
as well from the community and
doctors and others who have now
supporting evidence that
there's a lot more information
about near-death experiences
that many people now
have come forward to share.
So Karen is here from Virginia.
And she is a graduate of Cornell
in the London Business School.
So I'm very excited
to host Karen today.
And we'll host and
have her speak.
We have a short video
in the beginning.
And also, we'll have
question time at the end.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
KAREN HENSON JONES:
Good afternoon.
Thank you so much for coming.
I'm really happy to be here.
OK, so you just saw that
the trailer for the book.
And all those places
that you saw in the film,
they're all venues of the book.
So after I had this
very unexpected
near-death experience, then I
really had some huge questions.
Is there life after death?
If there is, which they're
definitely seems to be,
where do we go?
And so I found that there
are certain countries that
have a lot of
information about this.
I went to India, to
the kingdom of Bhutan,
to Israel, and to Italy.
And these are all the
venues in the book,
and I just investigated
these spiritual traditions
in these places.
So I'll just get started at kind
of the beginning of the story.
It's kind of surprising.
Seven years ago, I was
a 30-year-old woman
living and working
in London in finance.
I was living my parents' dream,
having graduated from Cornell
and gotten an MBA from
London Business School.
My life was full.
I had work, friends, great
clothes, great restaurants,
and travel.
I had no spiritual life at
all, and I was totally fine
with that, until
one day at lunch,
back in the States
for a vacation,
I suddenly blacked out
and slid onto the floor.
The next thing I remember,
I was strapped to a gurney
in the back of an ambulance.
At the hospital, I was
hooked up to EKG machine.
10 minutes later, a
doctor that looked
like Ben Kingsley's evil twin
entered the room and asked me,
has anyone in your family
ever died of sudden death?
Well, actually,
funny you should say
that, because just
a few days ago,
my cousin had died at
27 of unknown causes.
And I had another cousin who
laid down for a nap at 24
and never woke up.
Ben Kingsley did
not crack a smile.
With zero charm and compassion,
he informed me that I have
what's known as Long
QT syndrome, which
is a type of sudden
arrhythmia death syndrome.
That doesn't sound like good
news, I thought to myself.
I was then told I had to have
an ICD implanted into my heart--
or in layman's terms, an
Implantable Cardioverter
Defibrillator, which may
sound super and sexy and fun,
but I can assure
you that it is not.
An ICD is the size of
a pack of Winstons,
and it would
regulate my heartbeat
and shock my heart
back to life if it ever
just decided to stop.
In an instant, my
whole life changed.
Obviously, going back to work
in London was not an option.
And since, at that
point, I was forbidden
from even getting
on a plane, I had
to immediately resign
my job in London
and have all my stuff shipped
back to my parents' house
in northern Virginia.
I didn't know which
was worse-- being
told I had sudden death
syndrome or having to live
at home with my parents.
Luckily, the actual
procedure was
supposed to be low risk--
well, as low risk as implanting
a box inside your chest can be.
In fact, after the
operation, the doctors
told me that it
had gone perfectly.
Two hours later,
however, I woke up
with a searing, stabbing pain
in the center of my chest,
like a hook scratching
the inside of my heart.
The nurses and the
doctors brushed it off,
saying that it was normal, and
I was discharged and went home
to my parents' house to recover.
The next day, I injected
myself with a blood thinner
that the doctors had prescribed.
Immediately, I felt like venom
was rushing through my veins.
None of this felt normal, even
for having a pack of Winstons
in your chest.
I literally staggered
into my parents' bedroom,
and I said to my mother,
mom, I'm going to die now.
And I collapsed.
By the time the paramedics
arrived, I was not breathing
and I had no pulse.
I was taken to the
nearest hospital
by ambulance, where I was
cared for by the emergency room
staff, who are amazing but had
no expertise in ICD devices.
Nobody could figure out
what was wrong with me,
which is always comforting
when you're clinically dead.
And then a miracle happened.
A cardiologist by the
name of Dr. Khurana,
whose office was a
few buildings away,
had spontaneously
decided to take a walk.
Dr. Khurana was walking
through the emergency room
when one of the ER
staff recognized him
as a cardiologist,
a cardiologist who
had a specialty in ICDs.
And what was so
amazing about this
is-- I didn't write
it into the speech,
but it was actually a weekend.
So he had come in on a weekend
to catch up on some paperwork.
And he said that he
was in his office.
He had been doing
paperwork for hours.
He wanted a break.
So he got up to take a walk
and he met with his colleague
in the hallway.
And his colleague said,
what are you doing?
And he said, oh, I'm
just taking a walk.
And the colleague said,
oh, if you want to walk,
I'm just on my way out.
I'm leaving.
But I parked my car
near the emergency room.
Why don't you accompany me?
So they walked across
four buildings.
And Dr. Khurana was
walking through the ER
when one of the ER physicians
who had been working on me
recognized him as
a cardiologist.
And he saw him from
across the room.
And I'll never forget
this, because Dr. Khurana
is of the Sikh religion,
so he wears a turban.
And he said he saw his
turban, and he goes, oh,
that's the guy.
And he grabbed him.
And so Dr. Khurana was
walking through the ER.
The ER doctor recognized him,
and then he was called in.
And it was Dr. Khurana who began
the process of intervention
that ultimately saved my life.
And I don't think that I would
be here if Dr. Khurana wasn't
there at that moment.
So a few days later, I
open my eyes from a coma.
I later found out that I
had undergone two heart
surgeries and a lung operation.
It was also discovered
that the wire
from the lifesaving
defibrillator
had pierced my heart
and almost killed me.
Let me tell you,
there is nothing
like a medically-induced
coma to raise
existential questions--
you know, the standard what
heck happened to me?
Why are we here?
What is the purpose of my life?
Unfortunately,
I didn't have the answer
to any of those questions.
And for the moment, they had
to go into the back of my mind
as I had to tackle
a whole new reality.
The pain I experienced
was unbearable.
Before I left the
hospital, the doctor
had cut off my morphine drip.
And I begged him for more.
You don't know what that stuff
does to your brain, he told me.
And so I was discharged from
the hospital with nothing
more than a bottle of Tylenol 3.
My pain increased
tenfold when I realized
that I was going to have
to stay with my parents
for the foreseeable future.
They actually had to hire
assistants to help with my care
since I couldn't dress myself,
bath myself, walk unassisted,
or even write my own
name on a piece of paper.
I was completely debilitated.
And any thoughts
of a former life
had vanished, as had my hot
figure since at this point,
I had become permanently
hunched over in a C shape.
I needed calories for
my body to repair,
and I literally
couldn't stop eating.
There's so many
details in surgery
that I never knew about before.
I remember somebody
came to the hospital
and they brought healthy food.
They brought like a vegan and
kale soup, everything organic.
And the nurse shook her
head, and she said, no, she
needs burgers and fries.
She needs to eat
3,000 calories a day,
because the body is
repairing itself.
So I would just eat and
eat and eat and eat.
It was like you're
almost like an infant.
Like, I'd be sleeping
for a few hours.
Then I had to wait up and eat,
sleep for a few hours, wake
up and eat.
And my mom kind of had
to get on this schedule.
And she'd wake up at 1
o'clock in the morning
to make hamburgers.
So my mom would get up at
all hours to make me food.
And she always
said she was fine,
but I knew that the exhaustion
and stress were wearing on her.
As I detoxed from the
drugs, my legs shook,
and I suffered from
severe migraines.
I turned the lights
off to bathe,
because I couldn't bear to
see my long, extensive scars.
Needless to say,
I was emotionally
starting to lose it.
Under all this pain and
mess, however, I somehow
knew I was saved
by a miracle, be it
an angel, God, Jesus,
some divine presence.
The coincidence of Dr.
Khurana being in the ER
at the right moment
indicated to me
that there is something greater,
an organizing intelligence,
looking out for me.
I had started to believe that
my survival was too miraculous,
that I had lived for a
reason, even if I didn't
know what that reason was.
I'll spare you the details of
the next two years of my life,
and I'll just say
that they evolved
a lot of gut-wrenching physical
therapy, a lot of lying down,
and depression.
I was constantly
anxious over the future,
and angry over the unluckiness
of my circumstances.
I watched as all of my friends
hit the classic milestones--
promotions, engagements,
and getting jobs at Google.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
KAREN HENSON JONES: It's true.
It was really true.
And I felt that I
was being left behind
for the first time in my life.
Anything that my ego
had been attached
to-- my career, my looks,
my salary, my athleticism--
was either all gone
or disappearing fast.
I had to face my true self.
And without all of
those other things,
I wasn't sure who
that person was.
My whole family
was also struggling
on my behalf for solutions.
My father's constant
suggestion was to get a job.
As what, I wondered.
I was a C-shaped invalid.
And then one day, my
sister called and suggested
that I go to yoga and meditation
school in Los Angeles.
She had been learning it herself
to cope with the situation,
and she found it very helpful.
Yoga, I had practiced before;
but medication, never.
My sister told me that I
needed to go to this school
40 days in a row to create
a shift in my psyche.
I was desperate so I tried it.
I flew to LA and signed up.
At the center, I still felt
so much pain in my body,
even sitting down
was so painful,
let alone do the yoga positions.
But I just did my best, and I
just kept on going every day.
Our teacher was a woman named
Taje, and Taje means radiance.
She really emphasized
how important
our thoughts are in shaping
the kind of human being
that we become.
Every single thought
was imperative in terms
of maintaining a positive and
graceful personal projection.
She was teaching us to focus
on the best parts of ourselves
and to send those parts
out into the world.
She spoke about the power of
words and their importance.
Words are the
expressions of our soul.
And when we use them, we
can decide to elevate others
or to put them down.
Her point was to make
it a conscious choice
and to always stay
based in love,
both for ourselves
and for others.
This kind of vocabulary
was totally new to me.
And I realized that with all
the formal schooling that I
had had, nobody had ever
taught me how to think
or how to speak deliberately,
with positive intention,
self-love, and love for others.
That's what I was
learning in these classes.
And meditation, the art
of mastering our thoughts,
was, for me at
least, a missing key
to a greater level of happiness.
After a few days of
attending classes,
strange things
started to happen.
I actually felt
like I was healing.
I cried before going to sleep,
but they were tears of joy.
And no joke-- within 40
days, the color of my scars
had faded significantly.
I was becoming more mobile.
Those mysterious illnesses
that I'd been suffering from
were failing to appear.
Toward the end of my 40
days, the studio owner,
a yogi named Gurmukh, who's a
traveling diplomat and legend
in yoga world, taught a class
and spoke about the importance
of service.
If you were ever feeling
bad or depressed,
she said, you just serve or
uplift someone around you.
She said to find someone who
has that same problem you have,
and help them with it.
She said often, you
have two hands-- serve.
You have a heart-- love.
If you are lonely, pick up the
phone and call a lonely person.
If you are
heartbroken from love,
buy flowers for someone who
is also heartbroken from love.
And then by your
action and intention,
you're both uplifted.
It seemed to make sense to me.
After the class, Gurmukh was
always swarmed with students,
so I decided that the
best way to speak to her
was to a her in the bathroom.
I hovered by the sink quietly.
And when she emerged
from the stall,
I quickly told her
about my surgeries.
She put her hand on
my arm and asked me,
did you ever consider that
you chose this for yourself,
that your soul chose these
experiences before you
came to earth so
that you could grow?
Could you ever believe that?
My initial reaction
was, are you kidding me?
Do you have any idea
what I've been through?
Why would I ever choose this?
But somehow, the
seed of what she
had said-- that I, my
higher self or my soul,
may have set this all up for
my own growth and learning--
felt like it could
possibly be true.
The day before I left Los
Angeles to my parents' home
in Virginia, I saw a brochure
at the yoga studio for a teacher
training course in India.
Needless to say, I was
terrified of presenting the idea
to my parents.
They had barely
accepted my jaunt to LA.
And my father was
extremely anxious
about me returning
to normal life.
Swim back to the mainstream,
he kept on telling me,
demonstrating a freestyle
stroke with his arms.
Listen-- [LAUGHS] he would.
At breakfast, he would do this.
Swim back to the mainstream.
So listening to me
pray and meditate
for hours in my
childhood bedroom
was not his idea of me
getting my life back together.
He would complain constantly
about my meditating
and praying to my
mother and my sister.
Don't worry about it,
my sister told him.
It's like she's a nun.
She said, in another time
and place, she'd be revered.
And then my dad
said to her, well,
is that supposed to
make me feel better?
Because it's 2009.
So despite his resistance, I
knew that I had to go to India,
and my father was
just going to have
to deal with the situation.
Now, most of you have
probably never been to India.
Oh wait, I'm at Google.
How many of you are
actually Indian?
Well, I guess if you wanted
a break from your family,
the last place you
would go to is India.
Virginia, however, might
be an exotic option.
Once in India, I
arrived in a town
called Rishikesh, which
most people know about
because it's where
the Beatles went
to write the "White Album."
The ashram where they
stayed is now defunct,
but I was staying in a place
that was very close by.
It was a huge place-- totally,
totally different than what
I had expected.
I arrived at my destination
very late at night,
and to reach my
ashram, I had to walk
across a long, tall bridge over
what appeared to be blackwater.
As I walked by, scores of
beggars held out their hands.
Many were coughing, spitting,
limping, and heckling me.
I eagerly waited to arrive at
the sanctuary of the ashram.
When I was led to
my room, however, it
was not relief, but horror,
that washed over me.
The room resembled a
toilet in "Trainspotting,"
plus some bonus blood
splatters on the walls.
There is a large
window in the room,
but there were no glass
panes, and it was biting cold.
I asked to change
rooms, but I was denied.
I was a Beatle, so
what did I expect?
I sat on a green
plastic lawn chair
in the center of the room,
and I started to see it.
What was I thinking?
Did I really have a death wish?
And as I sat there,
bewildered at my circumstances
and imagining that Ewan
McGregor just might actually
come crawling out of
the loo at any moment,
I thought about the things
that I had been studying.
The voice of Gurmukh
came through.
What's the lesson here?
What am I being taught?
Had my soul chosen this
trip so that I could grow?
And so I began to repeat
to myself, I am lucky.
I am lucky.
I'm lucky to be alive.
I'm lucky to be walking.
I'm lucky to be breathing.
I'm lucky to have
a beating heart.
It was a tough sell for my
senses, but it was a start.
Daily meditations
at the ashram began
at 3:50 AM, which I didn't
know about before I got there.
There is no coffee, which
I also didn't know about
before I got there.
And the food was suitable for
an anorexic pleasure center.
But all of this deprivation and
my forced-change in attitude
had begun to take hold.
Without the comforts or material
pleasures that had been used to
and I was so attached
to, I had the energy
to focus on what was really
important there, which
was my spiritual growth, and
ultimately, the realization
that I didn't need
much to be happy.
And slowly, slowly, I
began to love everything
about my experience.
I was no longer consumed
by my circumstances,
and I decided to
focus on the gifts
that I was receiving instead of
the gifts that I was wanting.
One day, we had a lecture by
a teacher whose name is Siti.
Siti is a name that
means perfection.
These yogis all have
adopted, fantastic names,
and I suggest that you pick
one for yourself, as it will do
wonders for your dating life.
Siti spoke a lot about
the children of Rishikesh.
We encountered many
every day, and most
of whom begged for money.
She spoke specifically
of a boy that she
had met on the street
several years before.
He was born so contorted
that he could only
crawl on his hands and knees.
When she started
to tell this story,
I knew who he was right away,
because he actually was very
often right outside the ashram.
And he would walk on
his knees and his hands,
and he would wear
flip-flops on his hands
to protect them from the road.
So I knew who he was right away.
So when she saw him, she
started talking to him,
and she expressed concern
about his situation.
And she said, are you OK?
Who do you live with?
And he said he didn't
have any family
and that he didn't
live with anyone.
And so she said to him, oh, do
you mean that you are alone?
And he told her, I'm not alone.
I'm never alone.
I am always with God.
God is always with me.
Her heart went
out to this child,
and Siti arranged to
transfer him money
and to arrange shelter for him.
Thanks to her, he now sleeps
in a mattress in a room
that she rents for him.
She recently had taken
to buy him new clothes.
After he picked one sweater,
he seemed to be done.
When she prodded him to
get a second sweater,
he was completely puzzled.
Why, he asked?
I already have one.
The story moved me instantly.
Here, I have traveled
halfway around the world
and spent a mass of
money to try and find
what this homeless boy already
had-- the knowingness that we
are never truly alone,
and satisfaction
and gratitude for what
we already have in life.
Upon returning to
Virginia, I realized
that as much as I had
learned about gratitude,
there were still some things
that I was yearning for.
And so much to my
parents' delight,
I told them that I was
leaving, yet again, this time
for the Kingdom of Bhutan.
Why Bhutan, you might be asking.
Well, first let me ask--
any Bhutanese in the house?
OK, so for those of you
who are not familiar,
Bhutan is an
independent monarchy
between India and China.
And it's unlike any
other place on the planet
in that its government measures
the happiness of its citizens.
So it's hard to explain.
It's a monarchy, but it's
a very advanced monarchy.
So the people in the
government there, they go out.
They get a lot of
international education.
They go to the best schools
in the US and in England.
And they come back and they take
the best of this information,
and they combine it with their
culture, which is very deeply
ingrained in Buddhism.
So from farming to education,
all government policies
are based in Buddhist
spirituality.
Children meditate
from a young age,
and they repeat positive
affirmations in school,
like "I am happy."
Spiritual well-being
is essential
to the national identity.
Every two years, the government
distributes a happiness survey
to its citizens.
Questions like, "How many hours
a week do you spend in nature?"
point to a larger culture
of reflection and awareness.
Bhutan's social
concept of happiness
is not material
acquisition or competition,
but one of contemplation,
community, and connection
with nature.
It's more of a focus
on "we" as opposed
to a strong sense of "me."
It's no surprise that
I believed that Bhutan
would have some answers
as to how to be happy.
In Bhutan, I spent my days
meditating, and contrary
to all medical advice,
embarked on a hike,
high up into the mountains
to one of the oldest
nunneries in the kingdom.
The nuns ranged in age 13
to 84, so I was definitely
a prime candidate for them.
As I was leaving the nunnery,
one of the younger nuns
asked me if I had
any prayer request.
Oh, yes, I told her.
Please pray for the
right husband for me,
I said in all earnest.
She was flabbergasted.
A husband?
Why would you want a husband?
And I looked at her, confused.
She stretched out
her arms and she
said, do you think all of this
is possible with a husband?
Her reaction was a revelation.
I had begun to understand
that what really mattered
was my happiness in here and
now, in the present moment,
and not what any future
happiness may be.
For whatever reason, I had to
walk part of this path alone.
I had to find
happiness in myself
first before it could be
found in someone else.
And I think that's a
really good lesson.
OK, so after Bhutan, I decided
to go to another place known
for its peacefulness, quietude,
and the calm and patient
temperament of its
people-- Israel.
All joking aside,
Israel is known
for its deep, spiritual history.
And I had very much
wanted to go there.
Sadly, I don't have time
to go into great detail
on my many adventures there--
from the borderline cavity
search conducted by
suspicious Israeli airline
officer to a hot Israeli
actor who sat next to me
on the airplane-- but
you can read about it
my next book, "50 Shades
of the Middle East Heat
and Procreation."
I would like to share with you,
however, the journey of my trip
to a place in Israel
called Mount Meron.
So upon arriving in Israel,
I headed straight north
to the region of Galilee,
where I was going
to a place-- it's a mountain.
It's a synagogue,
actually-- which
is the burial site of
the founders of Kabbalah.
So the founders, it was really
this one particular rabbi
with his son.
And in the first century,
after criticizing Roman rule,
Rabbi Simeon and
his son, Eleazar,
were driven to hide
in a cave near Meron.
They lived in this
cave for a dozen years,
surviving only with a carob
tree and an underground spring
for water.
The deprivation is said
to have produced a bounty.
Rabbi Simeon was inspired to
write a sacred mystical text
called the Zohar.
Zohar means radiance.
It's also my new
name, by the way.
The text of the
Zohar illuminates
the nature of reality
and the path of the soul.
It discusses angels and
the parallel inner worlds,
all the things I never
believed in before my journey.
But now, they were becoming
as real to me as the ground
that I walked on.
Not everybody shared my
enthusiasm for Meron.
When I told the hotel manager of
my itinerary, he laughed at me.
He said, why do you
want to go there?
That place is for religious nut
jobs who pray for a marriage.
And perfect, I
thought to myself.
And so with this hope in mind,
I hopped in my rental car
and I headed to Meron.
But getting there was not
as easy as I had expected.
But rest assured, Google
Maps did not let me down.
And after a few random turns
into some military bases,
I was led to Simeon
and Eleazar's tombs.
The tombs were
surprisingly sunny.
A wall divided the women's
praying room from the men's.
Bookcases lined the walls.
Birds flew in and out.
Rabbi Simeon's tomb had
all the single ladies,
so I headed there first,
as kind of a joke.
Because these tombs,
they're really interesting.
So there's two tombs
that are in one room.
So it's the father and the son.
But the women and the
men pray separately,
so the room is
divided by a wall.
So you kind of get half a tomb.
Does that make sense?
OK, so Rabbi Simeon's tomb
had all the single ladies,
so I headed there first.
I put my hands on the
tomb, and I started
breathing deep and slow.
I didn't quite know
what to expect.
As I put my hands on
the tomb, the words
of the great Indian
prophet, Pantanjali,
came to mind-- "three aspects
of God-- creator, protector,
destroyer.
That is ecstasy."
I understood.
We are living the cycle of
creation and destruction
constantly.
The ecstasy is in the
renewal, the rebirth.
If all things were to
remain the same always,
if fantasies or the
material never dissolved,
we would never have the
joy in creating the new.
As I connected to the
energy from Eleazar's tomb,
I sent that mental images--
more time with my friends,
a wedding, a child, a home.
It perplexed me
that as much as I
had given to my
spiritual journey,
my desires hadn't really
changed that much.
But I realized that my attitude
toward attaining these things
had shifted dramatically.
I used to think that they
would bring me peace,
but now I realize that peace
can only come from within.
Suddenly, a blistered, old crone
with bleeding sores on her face
approached me.
She placed her hands on
both sides of my body
and forcefully spun me
around so that my forehead
was resting on the tomb.
I could feel the vibration
on my forehead, like energy
and a dizziness.
I felt energy, and I had visions
of myself dying over and over
again at different ages.
Somehow it was my
old self, my ego,
that was being laid to rest,
here, on this mountain.
After all I've experienced,
I'm convinced now
that death is not the end.
The journey I am on now,
however, is about life.
I no longer work in finance.
I've taken a different path
as an author and a meditation
teacher.
This life is a gift, and it is
up to us to embrace it fully.
Bring light to the
places in your life
where there are ashes.
We are all born
with the capacity.
When you find yourself
at a crossroads,
follow the path that
makes your heart sing,
because that is where the
true riches will be found.
That is my message to you.
For all of you here that are
not happy at Google, quit now.
Go be that masseuse that
you've always dreamed of being.
Go be that mountain
ranger at Yosemite.
Just kidding.
Whatever your situation
is, embrace it fully,
and realize that you are
here, now, for a reason.
And most importantly,
don't listen to your dad
when he tells you to swim
back to the mainstream.
Thanks.
RACHEL O'MEARA: Great.
[APPLAUSE]
So any regrets from
your prior life,
working in business to
what you're doing now?
Do you do miss it more
than you thought you would?
KAREN HENSON JONES:
I'm trying to think
about that, any regrets.
Ah, no, no regrets.
But I don't think
it's a terrible job.
I mean, I enjoyed my previous
job and enjoyed socializing.
I think when you're a
writer, it's very solitary.
And now, it's getting
a little bit better
for me, because I'm working
with people and my company
and my agency and
stuff like that.
But for a long time,
it was just me.
And so I definitely missed
the idea of going to work
and going with your friends.
AUDIENCE: You kind
of got a feeling
that your soul had taken you on
this path because of something
that you need to learn.
Have you, in your
meditation, got any clues
on why you needed
to go to this route?
Like, have you had any
clues of your previous lives
that didn't teach you this?
I'm getting deeper,
but I'm curious.
Like, in your medications, can
you go back to, for example,
your previous lives or why
you're on this journey?
Do you get any
pictures in your mind?
KAREN HENSON JONES: I do.
The information comes through.
There is a chapter in
the book on reincarnation
that's really fascinating.
So before jumping
to that, to what you
might see in a
previous life, let's
talk about the idea
of previous lives.
Because sound like you accept
it totally and everything.
So this is a really
interesting, because I
was born in a
Catholic household,
and I never heard about
reincarnation before.
And it was only
until I went to India
that I started hearing the word
reincarnation, here and there.
We would have lectures
from different teachers
and they'd kind of mention it.
But my interest in it, it
wasn't specifically profound.
And when I went
to Bhutan, they're
really focused on happiness,
but it's a little bit punitive
because one of their
focuses on happiness
is because they believe
that you will reincarnate
and that you have to be good so
that you will not have a lower
reincarnation, if
that makes sense.
So they're very much this
idea that be a good person
because you should be
a good person, but also
because of option B, that
if you're not a good person
and you come back, you
won't have a good life.
And I was on the airplane,
flying to the Bhutan,
and I was reading
the airline magazine.
They had a whole article
about reincarnation.
And there's another story,
which is when I was talking
to this nun in the nunnery.
When I said, please
pray for husband,
and she was flabbergasted.
And it kind of just
left the anecdote there.
But the conversation
actually continued.
And she was flabbergasted
because she said,
in my previous life, I prayed
so hard to be a monk because I
didn't want to be a wife
again, because I wanted
to have this time so
that I could explore
what it means to be human in
this world, is what she said.
So when I came up on
this trip from Bhutan,
I had a deeper interest
in reincarnation.
And I was already doing
research for the book.
And what I really wanted to find
out, after I had my experience,
I was so close to the other side
of the veil, I wanted to know,
is this my imagination, or
is there life after death?
Where's the evidence for this?
And so there's one
chapter in the book that
involves looking at what medical
science has to say about this.
And the University of Virginia
Medical School has a division,
and they study and they
document this kind of stuff.
So I called this guy, who is a
near-death experience expert.
He's a physician.
And I said, hi, blah, blah,
blah, I'm working on this book.
Do you think you could help me?
And he said-- all my research is
online-- he goes, but why don't
you talk to my colleague
who studies intersection
of reincarnation and biology?
It's something
really interesting.
And so he was literally
dropped into my lap.
So there is a chapter in the
book about the intersection
of reincarnation and biology,
and it's based on my interview
with this physician at the
University of Virginia Medical
School.
And it's just really,
really, really fascinating
because what they're doing is
they interview children who
are born with birth
defects that are
unexplained from
a medical basis.
But somehow, the children can
remember, in their past life,
where this defect came from.
So for example, there's
a girl with no legs.
And she'll say, oh yeah,
I got ran over by train.
And they'll just say it
totally matter-of-factly, oh,
in all my previous
life, just before I
died, ran over by train.
Or somebody who
had a deformed ear
said that he was shot by
somebody that he knew.
So they started going out-- team
of doctors would go to Asia,
and they would
record these stories,
interview the children.
And then they would
take the factoids
that the children were
offering and then they
would go compare
them against history,
and they find out
that they were true.
So children who were
born in one town
would give you extremely
detailed descriptions
of something that was
hours away to a place
that they had never been-- super
fascinating, super fascinating
stuff.
But your original
question was, what
was missing in my
previous incarnations
that I have to do this now?
That's a really good question.
I'll have to meditate on that.
But you know, it's
a lot of challenges.
It's a lot of challenges
that I've never
had before-- the challenge
of how to use the mind
to heal the body.
That was a huge learning.
The challenge of just living--
It's kind of like you're
in this paradox of,
you want to live in
here and now because you
want to really embrace
life so fully as a gift
and you just want to
stay extremely present.
But when you have
this experience,
you are reminded
that you will die.
And you just want
to ask yourself,
how did I live my life?
So it's living in
between those two places,
of living in the here and
now with a constant reminder
that we're all temporal, and
that you really want to not
regret and use the time wisely.
AUDIENCE: Is there a particular
religion, sect, ideology,
or anything that you
relate to the most
or that you stick
to the most now,
after all you've been through?
And then, is there a
religion, sect, ideology
that you completely dismissed--
KAREN HENSON JONES: Oh,
that's a really good question.
AUDIENCE: --as not going
to stick by you at all?
KAREN HENSON JONES: That's
a really good question.
I did study a lot of
different religions and sects,
going through the
different places.
And I think that before
all of this happened,
I wasn't a religious person.
I wasn't a spiritual person.
I had no interest.
And I think what surprised me is
how much good information there
is in every one.
So there are kind of like these
really great and really special
information in a lot
of different ones.
Right now, I'm studying Tibetan
Buddhism and meditation.
And I really love this
one, because I think
it's applicable to all humans.
The baseline is that we should
live our lives with compassion.
But that is also the main thread
of many religions and sects.
So more than anything, I
would say that's the takeaway,
is compassion.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
KAREN HENSON JONES:
Totally dismiss?
No, I don't think so, no.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
about before you went to LA,
you didn't have much
experience about meditation.
And what's the biggest
takeaway for yourself,
knowing about meditation?
And then the second
part of the question
is, when you're
comparing meditation
in different countries, do you
find any major differences?
KAREN HENSON JONES:
OK, all right,
let me see if-- I'll
go through this.
OK, what's the biggest
takeaway from meditation?
OK, so specifically,
in my personal case,
I use medication
to heal my body.
So I think for me, that was
the biggest takeaway, that you
can accomplish a lot with
meditation, which is just
a constant vigilance of
visualization and self-loving
thoughts.
But as it progressed
and as my body healed,
then I found meditation
was the most amazing tool
ever for happiness.
So it almost equals happiness.
And it's just because
you just keep yourself
in a really neutral state of
mind, a positive state of mind.
You connect to a higher source.
And it's something
that's really hard
to describe unless you begin
the process of experiencing it.
So the greatest takeaway for
meditation, peace in your life,
happiness in your
life, good health.
And is meditation
different across countries?
Yeah, I found it very different.
They all have their
different techniques.
And the different
techniques work
in different parts of the
brain, different vibrations,
different parts of the body.
They have different effects.
I mean, all of them
ultimately will bring you
to a state of deeper
connection, a deeper calm.
Even for those countries
that are very close together,
it's very different.
RACHEL O'MEARA:
I have a comment.
So at Google, we
have a practice here
to help people learn how
to be mindful and meditate.
And it's really, in effect,
to help manage stress levels
and just connect to,
internally, your own system
and feel compassion as well as
just have some time and space
that your mind can
rest or be quiet.
So for those that are here,
it's an opt-in process,
so it doesn't need to
be something that you
have to do it, by any means.
But what would you
recommend for people
who were interested in
this, curious about it,
but may not be able to know
how to start or do anything?
And they don't know if their--
maybe their body is OK.
They have no idea.
They just know that this is
something that is intriguing.
What would you recommend?
KAREN HENSON JONES: Ah, those
are really good questions.
It's very personal.
It's very personal to what
you might be attracted to.
Chade-Mang Tan, who
works here at Google,
has a book called
"Search Inside Yourself,"
and I think it's
perfect for this
because it's a very good
introduction to these concepts
and to these ideas.
So get "Search Inside Yourself."
And then I think a
great recommendation is,
for anybody who wants
to begin meditation,
is to try meditating in
short periods of time.
Like, it could be
quite challenging.
Some of you can start
with five minutes a day
or 10 minutes a day,
but make it regular.
Or to work with
guided meditation.
So there are a lot of really
good meditation teachers
that offer podcasts
and things on iTunes.
And that's a great way for
beginners to start, too.
Or you could just throw
yourself into the fire.
You could just go to Bhutan.
RACHEL O'MEARA: Go to Bhutan.
KAREN HENSON JONES:
Go to a monastery.
RACHEL O'MEARA: Or a mountain.
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: I was curious if you
have any thoughts on why there
are many people who can become
aware of habits that are not
serving what they may
see as a greater purpose
and who feel like, if I don't
change this I will probably
regret it-- it might
be very clear mentally,
but still are not able
to change their habit
and still get caught.
And then other people
will have something happen
where they are forced to.
KAREN HENSON JONES:
That's right.
AUDIENCE: Do you believe that
there is actually a reason,
that there's actually fate,
where some people are forced
by fate to face something
and take a different step,
and other people, it could
happen or it could not happen?
KAREN HENSON JONES: Yeah, I do.
This is so fascinating, because
this is sort of actually
the topic of my next
book because I'm
really interested in this
idea of fate versus choice.
I do think so.
And I think that maybe these
people, where fate really
reroutes them, are the people
who are never going to do it,
who are never going to change.
Does that make sense?
So yeah, I think there are
things that are very deeply
ingrained at the subconscious.
Everybody knows,
like, I shouldn't
eat five chocolate bars, but
maybe still do it anyway.
But why some people
and why not others
might go back to this question,
is it really the higher self?
Is it really the soul?
Is it something that they
want so badly that their ego
self just won't let them
do it that they get forced?
It's a great question.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thank
you for coming.
I guess this is less of a
question but more of a comment,
because I'm really intrigued by
when you mentioned that you had
felt that your soul had picked
the lessons that you're going
to learn or the
experiences that you're
going to have in this lifetime,
to learn certain lessons.
And I was just curious if you've
ever heard of Sylvia Browne?
Yeah, so she's a psychic medium.
And I read it years
and years ago.
She has a book called
"The Other Side and Back."
And she's usually on the
"Montel Williams" show,
back in the day.
And she's a psychic medium
who finds people who are dead
and things like that.
So she wrote a book called
"The Other Side and Back."
And this was the first time I
actually heard about this topic
that you're talking about.
So it's crazy that several years
later, you're talking about it.
I'm like, wow, I hadn't
thought about that in a while.
But she, basically in her book,
was talking about the fact
that we have souls or spirits.
And before we actually
come to this plane,
we map out our entire life.
So we choose the family.
We choose the friends.
We choose the
experiences that we have,
because it's for certain
lessons to learn.
And she even said that the
reason why we experience
deja vu is because our
souls put checkpoints
in our life to make sure
that we are reminded
that we're on the right path.
So deja vu is just
your soul telling you,
you're on the right path.
You're exactly where
you're supposed to be
and where you are.
So I thought it was
just really interesting.
So I guess in
saying all of that,
I wanted to know if you've ever
heard of her and that book.
And then the other
part was-- I guess
that's similar to some
of the other questions.
Do you feel like you have a soul
that chose all the experiences
that you are having in your
life to learn certain lessons,
and you fundamentally
believe that?
KAREN HENSON JONES: You know,
I'm still working on it.
I have heard of Sylvia Browne.
There's a very, very funny
article in "The Guardian."
It's a UK newspaper.
You can look it up-- about
a guy who was a reporter.
So he wanted to see if
she was valid or not.
And so he signed up for
a Sylvia Browne cruise.
It was very funny.
You can check it out, so
Sylvia Browne and the Guardian.
Yeah, do I think that
the soul chooses things?
More and more, I'm
believing that it does.
Sometimes, there
are coincidences
that are just so powerful
that I can ignore it.
So yeah, yeah, I do think that.
AUDIENCE: So I think
I'm just really confused
by the idea of having a soul
that chooses what you're
about to do and stuff, because
why would the soul choose to be
that poor little boy who's
on the streets in India
and permanently hunched over
and just begging for money?
I don't understand what
kind of lesson that is.
And if we say that, oh, it's
because in his previous life,
he did something wrong.
And then I'm like, well, does
everyone have reincarnation?
Because the
population growth, we
started with a much,
much smaller population.
So some souls will have to be
just like-- come up somewhere,
right, be created
somehow, because we
have a much larger population
in the world now than before.
And then when those
souls get created,
they're just like, OK, I'm
going to choose to be poor.
I just don't understand
how that works.
KAREN HENSON JONES: Me neither.
It was interesting because
when I went to University
of Virginia and I spoke to
this guy, Dr. Jim Tucker,
and he had written two
books about past lives,
I had assumed that he'd be
categorically like, yeah,
past lives, right, because
he's the one interviewing
all these kids.
So I said, so do you think
this is what's happening?
Are we all reincarnating?
And he said, not necessarily.
He says, I think for
these particular children
that I interviewed, it might
be a very good explanation
for what's going on.
And he said, but
is reincarnation
totally universal?
He's like, I don't know.
And it was really
mind-blowing to me,
because I was either
thinking, we are reincarnating
or we're not.
But it might not
necessarily be the case.
I mean, I think it's just
all such a huge mystery,
and we get more glimpses
of possibilities.
But it's always a mystery.
And something that he said at
the end of our conversation
together that I didn't
put in the book--
and when you talked
about deja vu-- he said,
would you ever believe
that you could reincarnate
and be the same identity?
So could you ever come
back and be yourself again
and make different choices?
Too much?
Yeah.
Too much, yeah.
Still stuck on past lives, yeah.
But if you look at the
contribution of this boy who
is India, would you ever have
thought that he's made it here
to Palo Alto on a video
that's going to be broadcast
potentially around the planet
with the lessons and the beauty
that he has to share?
So maybe that could
be his purpose?
RACHEL O'MEARA: Great, thanks.
And I know we could probably
sit here for a while
and keep asking questions,
but we do have to wrap up.
But if people have
more questions for you
out there or at
Google, where they go
to continue the conversation?
KAREN HENSON JONES:
I have a website
that has a lot of questions and
answers, a lot of information,
a lot of links to
more information.
It's www.karenhensonjones.com--
K-A-R-E-N. So check it out.
Thank you so much.
RACHEL O'MEARA: Great.
Thanks, Karen.
KAREN HENSON JONES: All right.
[APPLAUSE]